andrea quiere ganar algunos premios una
compañía de cereales está regalando un
premio en cada caja de cereal y la
publicidad dice colecciona los seis
premios cada caja de cereal tiene un
premio y cada premio tiene la misma
probabilidad de encontrarse en cualquier
caja andrea quiere saber cuántas cajas
necesita en promedio para obtener los
seis premios hay varias formas de
resolver el problema de andreas puede
encontrar una forma matemática para
determinar la cantidad esperada de cajas
que debe comprar en promedio para
obtener los seis premios o puede generar
algunos números aleatorios para simular
el recolectar caja tras caja y realizar
varias simulaciones para ver cuántas
cajas necesita para obtener los seis
premios por ejemplo puede decir que una
caja va a tener alguno de los seis
premios y puede asignar un número para
cada premio uno dos tres cuatro cinco o
seis después puede usar una computadora
para generar una cadena de números
aleatorios quizá algo que luce así en el
método general
puede comenzar con el número más a la
izquierda y decir esto es como si
comprara una caja de cereal esto me dirá
qué premio obtuve ella comienza su
primer experimento inicia con el número
a la izquierda y dice la primera caja de
cereal de este experimento o de esta
simulación me dio al premio número uno
continúa haciendo esto el segundo número
le dice que obtuvo el premio número
cinco en el tercero obtuvo el premio
seis y en el cuarto obtiene de nuevo el
premio seis ella continúa haciendo esto
hasta que obtenga los seis premios y
ustedes pueden decir que hay números que
no van del 1 al 6
tenemos ceros y ochos también tenemos 7
si 9 pero a estos números simplemente
los ignoramos pretendemos que no existen
y continuamos pausa en el vídeo y traten
de realizar el primer experimento si
usan los números de este primer
experimento suponiendo que esta es la
primera caja que obtienen en su
simulación cuántas cajas se necesitan
para obtener los 6 premios
hagamos una tabla la primera columna es
el experimento y en la segunda columna
tenemos el número de cajas que obtuvimos
en esta simulación usemos este color
para resolver el primer experimento
estamos en la primera simulación y
obtenemos el premio número uno vamos a
marcar los números de los premios que
recibamos 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
obtuvimos el 1 así que lo marcamos
tenemos el 5 y lo marcamos tenemos el 6
y lo marcamos también en la siguiente
caja tenemos otros 6 la siguiente caja
trae el premio número 2 que vamos a
marcar en la siguiente caja tenemos el 4
lo marcamos el siguiente número es un 7
así que lo vamos a ignorar la siguiente
caja tiene un 6 que ya tenemos ignoramos
el siguiente número porque es un 0 y en
la siguiente caja está el premio número
3 que es el último premio que nos
faltaba cuántas cajas tuvimos que
comprar vamos a contar sólo las cajas
que traían números válidos del 1 al 6
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete y
ocho cajas en el primer experimento así
que en el experimento número uno
necesitamos ocho cajas para obtener los
seis premios hagamos otro experimento ya
que esto no nos está diciendo el
promedio de las cajas que se deben tener
para conseguir los seis premios lo único
que nos dice es que en este experimento
se requirieron ocho cajas si queremos
calcular el promedio tenemos que
realizar varios experimentos y mientras
más experimentos hagamos será más
probable que nuestro promedio prediga
adecuadamente la cantidad de cajas que
debemos obtener en promedio para
conseguir los seis premios hagamos el
experimento número dos recuerden que es
importante que estos números sean
realmente aleatorios por lo que ahora
comenzamos con el siguiente número
válido tenemos 12 lo marcamos tenemos un
1 lo marcamos el que sigue es un 8 que
no contamos luego sigue otro 2 ya lo
tenemos ignoramos el 9 sigue un 5 que
marcamos
el siguiente 9 luego sigue un 4 que no
tenemos y que marcamos siguió un 3 que
tampoco tenemos y que también marcamos
el 1 ya lo tenemos el 3 también lo
tenemos de nuevo sale el 3 después el 2
que ya tenemos de nuevo otro 2 ignoramos
el 0 ignoramos estos que ya tenemos y
finalmente tenemos un 6 que es el premio
que nos faltaba cuántas cajas
necesitamos en el segundo experimento 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 y
17 cajas así que en el segundo
experimento andreas necesito 17 cajas
para tener los seis premios podemos
continuar con esto así que hagámoslo una
vez más es algo extrañamente divertido
experimento número tres
recuerden que nos interesan solamente
los números válidos por lo que ignoramos
los números que no corresponden a los
premios
tenemos el 4 lo marcamos
no son válidos luego tenemos el 5 que
marcamos que se repite aquí tenemos el 2
marcamos los 3 siguientes no son válidos
ahora tenemos el 6 marcamos 7 no es
válido luego el 1 marcamos se repite el
1 el 9 no vale el 12 es repetido el 9 no
vale el 1 ya lo tenemos y finalmente
tenemos el 3 que nos faltaba cuántas
cajas válidas tuvimos que tener en este
experimento 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 para
estos tres experimentos cuál es el
promedio
8 17 + 10 entre 3 25 10 35 entre 3 nos
da 11 enteros y dos tercios sabemos si
es este el verdadero número teórico de
cajas que esperamos para poder obtener
todos los premios no lo sabemos pero
mientras más experimentos realicemos más
se acercará a nuestro promedio al verdad
el promedio teórico